we call a few fun things now you can let
me know in 30 seconds if they're fun uh
whoever won the most takes Hobbes are
Shaw ruin the most definitely that's a
joint and because they crack up together
I'd be like please guys both you both
you yeah who was more likely to get it
on the first take Hobbes Horschel
Oh again that's impossible I can't doing
who would be a better wingman
Hobbs or sha these are really hard did
he what does he say sha sha sha sha sha
he had funny answers to a lot of this
did he did he did he did he we're
talking about Statham I'm taking yeah
I'm asking this of Dwayne and white I
know right wait wouldn't you go to white
oh my god they're there now no yeah
crazy oh my god um so who was it was
maybe a better wingman probably Statham
because Dwayne would just he's so
massive you wouldn't be able to get him
in places okay um who's faster leaving
their trailer Hobbes our shop sure who
was more hair Hobbes or Shaw dead
equally I saw them face up just me booty
I won't ask you this one uh who was
faster at learning their lines Hobbes
our Shaw I would say Hobbes actually
okay um this is where we're gonna do
some fight questions yeah so here we go
we'll see if you know any of these
things who would win in a fight uh
Hobbes in Shaw or Jason Bourne
Pop's is Sean Hobson Shaw or Deadpool
Deadpool clubs in Shaw or John wick
publish or hubs in Shaw or John McClane
die hard don't make thing yeah I was in
Shaw or the Terminator equal I think no
it's not you Terminator today Oh pubs in
Shaw or rock clubs in show what if rocky
has a theme music in the sea rocky hubs
in Shaw or Thanos Avengers endgame
how about schema the Avengers okay I
liked loads of friends it is I feel
terrible yeah is that is that thought
yeah yeah no this is the big guy Josh
Brolin played him the real real evil guy
oh I love Josh I'll say him - Shaw or
the predator
like Schwarzenegger you know predator I
think what some jokes the double prong
effect you know that they've got the
advantage here
Hobson Shaw or Chev Chelios which is
Jason Statham in prank hopes is sure
like it's like yeah was funnies that's
the first one that Statham said that
that Chef Julio's could win he said oh
because it's moping him that's like
Hobson shot or Bruce Lee Bruce Lee
Hobson Shaw or Indiana Jones
Hobson Shaw or Wolverine just wolverine
up the clueless Wolverine he just be
like clubs in Shaw or Sigourney Weaver
and aliens so anyway of every time Hobbs
and Shaw or Sarah Connor from terminator
cut everything Wow we got it
Hobbs and Shaw or Liam Neeson and taken
Hobbs is Shawn okay this is it you were
pretty honest about these and I
appreciate that yeah
moving into real [ __ ] one of the things
I love about the franchise Fast and
Furious in Hobbes and Shaw is that the
movie knows what the movies know what
they are and they have these crazy
over-the-top moments yeah do you have a
favorite over-the-top moment in the Fast
and Furious movies
it's always crazy over the toppers no I
think I mean I don't know it for me it
was like when the reality of like doing
actually picking me up with his with his
one arm that was like this is ridiculous
but I completely believe it yeah I love
that in the theater like all of us
screamed I don't I mean it's just such a
crazy you know anyways David before
shooting began which part of the script
were you most excited to film and why I
think it was like I think it was the
fight with Duane actually cuz that was
the first thing I read David sent me
like a previous fight choreography of it
and when I saw that I was like oh my god
wait a minute this is an opportunity to
like really change how women and you
know alongside the men in this very
alpha male world and genre and when I
realized that Duane would let me beat
him up you know and that that that
happens within the first few minutes of
meeting the character that like seemed
like a almost like a responsibility to
be like yes we can create a woman in
this environment who's like totally
their equal who doesn't get saved she
was like as capable of fighter that does
all her own stuff and that was like
really exciting I'm curious
obviously really very physical role
which day did you leave set completely
black and blue and why most days
like boasting um just ebrill from like
basic punching your arm so yeah you know
like you have to do it so many times in
a row and and you're just taking all
over like weird parts of your body you
just keep random it will just be this
part like in agony or like you know and
they have physios they're a lot of time
and like you put ice on it and then you
just gallop in the next morning like
okay you have to take it or we're taking
your friend and keep going yeah my last
question for you I'm curious you get the
script before shooting begins how much
is the movie exactly what you got how
much it's a changing almost a different
it changes every morning really well
because the locations change it's
something the guys find something new
and then like you have to rework things
and yeah missions the same it's never
the same as what you originally
completely um congratulations on the
movie thank you for indulging me on
these stupid questions